c'est un double crime pour vous aussi
jean vincent placé comme l'a dit le
sénateur bruno retailleau contre une
famille et également contre la france je
crois que nous partageons tous le même
sentiment le même
ressenti par rapport à ce drame
épouvantable ce crime odieux et ça a été
dit très bien par le président larcher
par bruno retailleau par françois
zocchetto part bien sûr le premier
ministre le ministre l'intérieur n'est
pas en politique sur de l'ensemble des
bons politique c'est l'effroi et la
consternation donc évidemment une pensée
très émue pour les victimes pour ce
malheureux petit garçon qui est lui bien
sûr à la chance d'être encore là mais
qui sera bouleversée baissé toute sa vie
et bien sûr l'ensemble des proches des
des familles est évidemment salué des
policiers les gendarmes qui se retrouve
avec ses collègues et cette campagne qui
était également d'ailleurs membre de du
corps du ministère de l'intérieur donc
ce sont d'abord les victimes bien sûr
c'est aussi là t'as crête à la france
avec cet individu qui se revendiquait de
l'état islamique sa dette à terme et non
justement cet individu qui en est fait
vous l'avez indiqué était suivi depuis
plusieurs années oui par nos services de
renseignement et a impliqué et même
condamné pour sa participation à une
filière de condamner condamné bien sûr
et qui ensuite à exécuter d'ailleurs sa
peine et qui se retrouve là au corps
dans un pas supplémentaire dans cette
dans cette folie barbare
des voix s'élèvent à droite pour
réclamer que ces individus qui sont
repérés donc un soient placés dans des
centres de rétention
qu'en pensez vous faux je pense même que
celles et ceux qui portent ce type de
proposition savent que ce n'est pas
possible
et j'en suis même sûr que si j'étais au
gouvernement ils ne feraient pas sur
quelle base juridique
sur quelle base juridique eh bien on
peut mettre des gens ainsi dans les
centres de rétention
s'il ya une base juridique de toute
façon il ya une écoute il y a peut-être
un mail il ya eu une interception d'une
quelconque communication et de toute
façon cela sont appréhendés parce qu'il
ya à fait générateur
sur quelle base on mettrait des
individus quel individu en rétention
administrative
cela me paraît extrêmement éloigné de ce
que il sait qu'il est possible de faire
en terme de droit et ne se remettra chez
elle et adroit notre démocratie et je
pense même d'ailleurs que il faut
essayer d'éviter de faire ce type
d'effets d'annoncé parce que les mesures
qui sont là ont vocation à être déployé
davantage
et d'ailleurs il ya aussi un travail au
niveau européen à faire enfin on a
progressé sur le pnr notamment pour
pouvoir suivre les uns et les autres le
fassent aérien le joueur ayant eu un
code qui permet de suivre à la trace les
individus au sein de mais là on est face
à ce que par exemple la sénatrice que
vous connaissez bien nathalie goulet
nomme les djihadistes de proximité c'est
à dire oui ceux qui sont sensibles à ce
discours de l in your house sur dix n'a
pas sur internet et le premier ministre
l'a dit très clairement de façon
extrêmement lucide il n'y a pas de
risque zéro il n'yad'ailleurs de risque
zéro dans aucune activité et donc qu'il
l'a il faut assumer je vous dis
renforcer encore les moyens intensifiée
et d'ailleurs qu'il me soit permis aussi
de saluer le travail formidable des
forces de police et de gendarmerie qui
sont déployés pour lutter contre le
terrorisme qui sont déployés aussi dans
la protection de l'euro 2016 tous les
grands événements et puis aussi surtout
au quotidien tout est alors 16 et tous
les français
c'est une guerre dit manuel valls mais
pour marine le pen c'est le crime de
trop elle estime que la lutte implacable
contre l'islam il doit enfin commencer
donc pourrait ça n'a pas véritablement
commencé dans notre pays que répondez
vous le dépouillement des moyens je
viens de vous le dire est tout à fait
significatif est tout à fait remarquable
nous sommes dans les difficultés que
nous avons pu rencontrer sur les
questions budgétaires nous avons déjà
assumé le sérieux budgétaire qui porte
ses fruits nous parlerons j'imagine du
retour de la croissance
et dans cette situation nous nous avons
fait des choix politiques soient très
très claires en matière de protection
des biens et des personnes ont pas de
faire de lutte contre le terrorisme
je voudrais pas rappeler non plus dans
le quinquennat précédent qu'elle a été
par exemple la courbe de décroissance du
nombre de nos militaires et cette
réalité y compris président la
république à assumer en revenant en sur
le plan budgétaire sur ce qui a été
prévu en termes également de sérieux
budgétaire en matière militaire
eh bien on voit que sur l'ensemble de
ces sujets la police gendarmerie
militaire
renseignements initiatives au niveau
national fermeture et contrôle des
frontières le fait que nous ayons été
extrêmement volontariste au niveau
européen le fait que nous sommes dans la
coalition pour lutter contre l'état
islamique dahesh en syrie en irak et les
choses sont claires j'échoue croit
d'ailleurs que ça me saluer au niveau
mondial et respectée au niveau européen
pour notre détermination à qui on l'a
compris donc la levée des barrages
franchement sur l'action du gouvernement
ne va pas de donner de leçons de quoi
que ce soit et qu'elle essaye
d'entretenir les peurs les haines en
cherchant à diviser et ses ailes en
réalité qui être quelque part la
philosophie la stratégie de neige qui
consiste justement et c'est diviser
notre pays alors que dans des périodes
comme aussi difficile que celle ci comme
de suite au drame notamment dit hier
l'unité le rassemblement sont vraiment
les éléments essentiels pour la cohésion
nationale
deux fois ministre a dit qu'il y avait
une haine anti-flic c'est votre avis
également
je trouve que c'est tout à fait
incroyable que alors que notre pays dans
cette situation alors que on a connu ce
drame terrible et et bien il y ait
encore des gens qui je ne confonds pas
des manifestants et les casseurs bien
sûr mais qu'il y ait encore des gens qui
puissent 5 régé dans des manifestations
qui sont évidemment pacifique pour aller
dans des magasins détruire des
devantures l'hôpital necker mais enfin
un escroc se rencontrent de quoi il
s'agit on se demande aussi comment est
ce qu'il est possible que ces gens
viennent dans les manifestations pour
casser ça fait des semaines que ça dure
malheureusement c'est pareil c'est assez
fréquent c'est assez difficile parce
qu'il suffirait qu'il y ait une
intervention plus musclée plus sévère de
la police et que évidemment dans cette
espèce de 2 d'espacé l'e3 où il ya tout
à la fois de manifestants sympathique et
pacifique et le casseur on se retrouve
vite 0 qui n'existe pas de la même
manière là on ne peut pas il faut la
police ferrand son maximum et laisser
d'intervenir avec d'ailleurs respect des
manifestants et du droit de manifester
et quand il ya ces casseurs là il faut
intervenir très rapidement les isoler et
c'est extrêmement difficile à réaliser
bien sûr ça a assez duré évidemment que
c'est assez duré et d'ailleurs je le dis
moi je ne confonds pas ni les
manifestations ni les grèves
avec aussi ce qui s'est passé sur le
blocage des raffineries des stations
service des ports ça c'est inacceptable
c'est inacceptable et la cgt et
commencent d'ailleurs à le comprendre
y compris le retour autour de la table
de monsieur martinez la table de
discussion qu'il nous dise madame qui
est numéro 2 la cgt dit ah enfin on va
en discuter mais
ça fait six mois qu'on leur dit qu'on
est prêt à discuter à il ya eu le
rapport
combrexelle qui dit un an un an c'est la
personne n'a voulu j'aurais entre le 49e
voulait disputer un passage
parlementaires qu'ils soient des
fanatiques du 49.3 mourinho c'est
passionnel est d'ailleurs le droit
d'utiliser 49,3 était fortement réduit
ces mêmes panneaux c'est la révision
constitutionnelle de 2008 de nicolas
sarkozy entend mieux une deuxième fois
son logo si ça continue comme ça oui
quand on a la chance dans un quinquennat
comme celui ci d'avoir un président de
gauche
oui et une majorité de gauche et il
suffit de voir ce qui est en train de
faire le sénat et la droite par rapport
au texte je voudrais quand même là vous
fait rire laurent comprennent bien que
c'est pas lui
ce dieu diriger ce pays basque se voit
mal un président communiste pour la
france et bien c'est les options et je
le dis aussi je respecte aussi jean luc
mélenchon mais je pense que ce sont des
gens qui sont durablement minoritaires y
compris par rapport à leur vision du
mouvement sur la droite et je dis juste
que la haine aujourd'hui elle est simple
le choix le simple qu'on le veuille
qu'on le veuille pas le choix il est sur
la politique portée par le gouvernement
ou alors ce que fait la droite
ou alors ce qu'elle s'éclate et quand je
vois en clair c'est un jeu très claires
ce qui se passe au sénat bien sûr c'est
la remise en cause des 35 heures
c'est aussi le fait pour le coup qu'il y
ait un ultralibéralisme en réalité
aujourd'hui le projet de droite ils
doublent sur la droite
thatcher et reagan des années 80
hélas depuis 18 mois depuis la sortie du
gouvernement dont il ya une divergence
très forte avec david comment avec
cécile duflot et puis son tir tas de la
majorité de ceux qui est resté et ce
n'est pas le sujet ce n'est pas une
conséquence à la rupture avec le ps
le vrai sujet c'est la ligne 2 je suis
tout seul à 2% et j'ai raison
quand vous avez jalouse la question de
quelle est l'utilité de se positionner
pour les convaincre de ne pas travailler
deux mois je vous y feront ce qu'ils
veulent maintenant
d'ailleurs c'est que cécile duflot se
prépare oui maîtresse à la répéter
pareille pas de problème de personne au
contraire moi j'avais j'aime plutôt et
david cormand et cécile duflot à titre
personnel mais d'évidence quelle serait
l'utilité d'une telle candidature
elle elle accuse presque nommément
françois hollande
en tout cas le gouvernement la majorité
et c'est d'assassinats politiques un peu
désagréable il faut pas confondre le
suicide et d'assassinats
il faut assumer sa part de
responsabilité
vous êtes s'attireront gillant
écologique du quinquennat j'ai bien sûr
j'aurais préféré plus et je vais même
vous dire j'aurais préféré que ça
commence plutôt parce qu il aura fallu
assez bizarrement attendre peut-être et
que justement il y ait cette sortie du
gouvernement
cueillis sont tous là comme 21 pour que
notamment ceux qui sont les plus
écologistes
regardez je vais vous dire je trouve que
ségolène royal a été plutôt efficace et
nous la chance que nous avons
aujourd'hui c'est que ségolène royal
elle se bat sont au sujet sur glee sofa
glyphosate et elle se bat sur les
perturbateurs endocriniens et le combat
qu'elle mène à commission européenne est
saluée y compris parfois sur l'huile de
palme et des produits bien connu du
l'huile de palme ça n'a pas été facile
tellement son volontarisme et elle a
enfin vous devons n'est aujourd'hui d un
pays qui démontre dans le monde une
forme d'excellence environnementale
capable jeune candidat écolo en 2010 un
candidat écolo qui pourrait gagner
hier il y aurait un candidat écolo qui
pourrait gagner et son présidentielle
comme par exemple le verts autrichiens
mais le candidat autrichien par le
candidat autrichien il est ou alors nous
sommes sur sa ligne politique où il est
sur notre politique une écologie
entrepreneuriale in an que logique et
intègre le réel une écologie qui
s'appuie sur l'économie verte notamment
pour faire progresser d'écologie vous
souhaitiez que françois hollande soit
candidat bien c'est gentil mais que
c'est le meilleur candidat pour
l'écologie s'il y avait un candidat
écologiste pur sucre le président de la
république est socialiste et je pense
social démocrate mais c'est à lui de se
qualifier s'il y avait un candidat
écologiste qui soient en situation de
pouvoir gagner ça pourrait s'évaluer
mais d'évidence il n'existe pas et donc
à partir de ce moment là dans le champ
de la gauche
le meilleur candidat c'est toujours
qu'on le veuille qu'on le veuille pas le
président la république appuyée sur ce
bilan de la coop 21 et de l'action de
ségolène royal et donc je peux vous dire
que je suis alors extrêmement à l'aise
non pas dans tes baskets moi je n'ai pas
de basket mais les chaussures pour
assumez bien sûr le soutien clair à
celui qui a réussi la cap 21 et à la
politique du gouvernement dont celle de
ségolène royal qui me soit permis aussi
de saluer mes collègues barbara pompili
émanera look et leur secteur vous avez
évoqué cécile duflot vous dit elle s'est
suicidée en fait elle a conclu son
solent de meurtres politiques vous
l'avez dit alors il ya un autre candidat
qui hésite lui alors que cécile duflot
se prépare c'est nicolas hulot oui bonne
affaire qu'on faisait alors très
sincèrement j'ai constaté que j'ai
constaté que les verts le soutiennent en
espérant qu'il n'y aille pas pour
pouvoir recommencer leurs divisions pour
désigner un candidat à brasc ils sont
quand même réussi à 3000 personnes à
voter en france avoir cinq motions ce
qui est quand même juste incroyable le
mes amis communistes j'ai un peu
l'impression que pour ceux qui disent
hulot c'est pour éviter
mélenchon et mélenchon lui ce qu'ils
voudraient c'est que hulu le soutiennent
dont il fait l'impression qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui soutiennent
faussement c'est françois al-sibaa je
pense que ce serait le plus cohérent
parce que s'il ya quelqu'un aussi qui a
oeuvré pour la réussite de la coop 21
sous l'autorité du président de la
république c'est nicolas hulot a été
évidemment une arme extraordinaire enfin
je suis plutôt dire et en pacifiste à un
joker extraordinaire dans la réussite de
la cap 21 et ce qu'il a fait eh bien il
a oui le poids avoir vocation à le faire
dans un deuxième quinquennat et je crois
soit d'origine pour le coup était très
clair je ne vois pas moi je vous dis
très clairement entre
mélenchon qui est une offre politique
incontestable sur le fond qui n'est pas
la nôtre qui devait joker alors je suis
fini ma phrase donc jean luc mélenchon
et françois hollande il ya eu il y avait
eu des gauches différentes c'est
incontestablement très diverses mais
j'ai l'impression quand même très
sincèrement que même si vous y accorder
beaucoup d'audience aux uns et aux
autres
entre le pc et les frondeurs en réalité
dans l'opinion dans l'opinion
entre jean luc mélenchon et françois
hollande mais il n'y a rien derrière y a
personne à personne
d'accord jean luc mélenchon a fait une
conversion enfin s'est converti au logis
très très clairement qu est ce que vous
pensez de sa fabrication écologique
d'ailleurs son écologie ressemble
beaucoup à celle des verts actuellement
c'est à dire que c'était il y avait chez
les verts plusieurs courants y compris
moi même j'ai animé le courant et à
l'eau pragmatique entrepreneuriale et
j'assume et
aujourd'hui sur luc mélenchon
incontestablement et moi je crois je
suis pas de raison de ne pas croire à sa
sincérité
bon avant il était plutôt ultra jacobins
je crois qu'il est toujours un peu
contrariant régionales mais bon il est
il était plutôt pro-nucléaire
il était plutôt productiviste la sortie
il a évolué et je dis moi je préfère les
converti à l'écologie que ceux qui ne
parlent pas du tout d'écologie donc il
est convertie etc il le fait bien avec
le talent qu'on lui connaît tant sur le
plan culturel rhétorique la qualités
oratoires après qu'on a dit ça en fait
c'est écologique il incarne c'est ce
terme d'ailleurs qu'il n'utilise plus
sur la planification écologique
c'est-à-dire une vision quasiment
marxiste de l'écologie qui est
d'ailleurs un peu celle des verts en
réalité les verts aujourd'hui je suis
pas sûr qu'ils ne finiront pas avec
mélenchon tellement ils sont devenus
d'extrême gauche et non mais pour en
revenir à jean luc mélenchon nous avec
lui des oeufs
j'ai l'honneur de présider union des
démocrates écologistes avec jean luc
bennahmias et ceux de rugy avec d'autres
nous nous voulons avoir une écologie
n'ont pas seulement réaliste et
pragmatique mais je le répète
entrepreneuriale avec moi je pense que
pas un seul instant que ce sont les
normes les contraintes c'est pour ça que
je sois simplification mais pas
seulement vont aider la protection de
l'environnement une classe juste une
phrase je pense qu'aujourd'hui avec le
monde l'économie qui se développe ainsi
et notamment l'économie verte est une
chance extraordinaire tout à la fois
pour la planète et pour l'emploi c'est
en aidant les grandes boîtes à la
conversion écologique à la conversion
même si c'est au départ je vais dire des
noms total veolia
le point de départ edf lorsque edf se
lancera totalement et dans l'énergie
renouvelable et bien ça fera un vain mot
pas seulement les petites éoliennes
convoi par ci par là mais c'est cette
transformation la à laquelle je veux
vrai et je pense que franchement je
serais bien plus utile à la planète que
justement ceux qui sont là en train de
regarder avec des jumelles on se
rapprochant de l'ex majordome d'un mot
sur et des effets sur ségolène royal
vous lever rendu hommage et vous
soutenez sa décision de dates approuvé
la prolongation de la de vie des
centrales de délire de designer est ce
qu'on peut me répondre oui ou non
mais c'est impossible le passage de
votre question est tronqué à répondre à
une question troqué changer la loi de
transition énergétique des des choses
très clair qu'on va aller vers 50% de
nucléaire dans la production
d'électricité en est à 74 %
toute la droite a dit 'nous on reviendra
sur la houle sur la loi donc pareil pour
les écologistes c'est la droite qui veut
revenir sur la loi où nous et nous nous
devons alors pour oeuvrer parce que vous
avez la lumière vous avez mis pas rêver
là parce que plus il fait très chaud il
ya énormément de lui vous avez la
lumière c'est parce que il ya
d'électricité donc moi je ne suis pas
pour le retour à la lampe à pétrole
serait bien ennuyé mais manqua
révolution alors là je vous dis juste
une chose très simple et bien pour faire
en sorte que ça continue sur une
mutation de 10 ans oui il faut prolonger
d'accord voilà votre réponse wallace est
oui alors à moi de vous
non je finis ma phrase le second sur wii
en même temps il faut enfermer
c'étaient les centrales c'est à dire
qu'on prolonge de dix ans quelques unes
un peu comme les voitures par exemple
vous savez et je finis pour sortir du
diesel déjà il ya combat politique on va
finir par sortir du diesel parce que
déjà avant c'était 80 % la chatte dz
battant déjà soir écouter écouter quand
vincent passé ne peut pas le faire en
deux ans parce que par exemple vous si
vous avez acheté deux voitures diesel
hier eh ben je peux pas vous demander de
la vente demain